for you at 135 you know you got morob
you got you got some pretty good
contenders are you looking obviously
we're not looking past Sterling yeah
after I'll draw I definitely you know I
plan on sticking around 35 for a while
45 definitely in in the future but I
would like to defend the buff at 35.
like you said we're not looking
pathology I understand how big of a test
and how you know difficult of a fight
this could be but I also know that I can
put his lights out the way he marches
forward as far as who would be next I
want that Cheeto rematch back Corey you
know people think that's a that's a big
fight kind of a big fight Corey's
probably like the worst guy at promoting
himself and Rob yeah definitely there's
already you know a little story behind
that one especially being Al Joe's
friend uh who else is up there Rob font
just had a beautiful performance over
Adrian Jonas yeah that's amazing yeah
yeah so there's a lot of possibilities I
truly believe me versus any of those
guys is a massive fight just because uh
I feel like you know people want to see
me win